quadruple pawns so close was this close
to us um now okay let's suppose we're
let's have a scotch one scotch go now
come on I wonder this scotch that's my
vision b5 check hmm a place sharp line
is there a sharp line here maybe no
sharp line Queen e2 I guess no one's
playing quickly to keep up pace oh it's
Hoggy good morning taki how's it going
if you're just joining I almost talked
about Drupal pawns it was so cool almost
okay now I have amazing lights
actually I have to be careful here I
have to be very careful
save the queen I think I just want to
bail out with this phone yeah
oh you saw the last game nice what to do
f3 always playoff 3 solid move after you
get the rock off this diagonal
yeah I'll play d4 yeah
ooh zip g5 no f4 now what's some yeah
there's some comp some comp I'll play h3
could even take I should have taken
Queen d7 coming
Jack
Jack where's my meat its defends and
attack or attacks in defense
whichever way th to
turning this okay let's go ooh
orchestrate g5 mates g5 meet incoming g5
let's go g5 mates ah you didn't let me
g5 mates
yeah g5 mates let's go g5 mate g5 emo
time let's go let's go
okay g5 mate I haven't had one of those
in Ohio and okay only 200 points away
from first actually 197 points away from
first with that win g5v for low that's
in your name kawaki good night
also a good morning kept playing Jumanji
to keep the zhurqis I was wait doing
here I was waiting it's Castle queenside
intriguing
maybe five is nice
efore oh good move like he needs some
[ __ ] a little bit of calm
not much cop what to do III have to go
for it
I'll put the light on g5
now I'm getting forked again
hmm
never resign when you have nights
actually I should probably resign
fifty-one seconds left but some
attacking ideas
I need a miracle that's a good
[Music]
there's one trick there's one trick
oh there's no tricks I resign back to
tournament Oh what did you type is ooh
forget this opponent berserks back yeah
okay whatcha playin is d4 play this line
yeah this is all pretty much kind of a
generic setup b5 included play b6 extra
safe that's a good move play this
beginning for G 4 I can take a 4
it's getting weird like we have six want
to take here right here
count attacking a queen d5 or the move
let's play this move sum up the exchange
should be winning opponent what's the
draw I don't want to draw a g5 ooh got
four ok dirty flag coming he's still
life in this position plant my king on
f5 check from the side now the Kings cut
off play the smooth hmm hurts me
progress
let's check from behind walk around oh
yeah sorry about that but that's what's
the nature of blitz ok riding up some
buzzer King points trying to catch up to
Shawn whoa so much uptime so much uptime
I still want to play a scotch midnight
Rhino are you still here
maybe not the very weird name is back
they my longest dream ever before this
was like 9 hours but yeah I'm not gonna
be too much longer
a point wants a draw no I think there's
some rule that you can't
if you accept draw too early then oh I
forgot summers urk coups Moses we play
the game earlier okay
I'm talk I was past quotes Midnight's
gone
oh no but midnight the Rhino or midnight
the time or both
let's play a smooth
I mean night the Rhino that happened us
and take this
okay not sure about this
oh this is just pretty bad unless it's
okay ooh sorry about that mouth slip the
other position was not good for me and
mouse lips are I guess part of the game
I still want to play a scotch played so
many games haven't had a single scotch
okay I think what I'll do I'll play
until I lose and then I sleep how about
that Mel berserk so maybe I'll get this
over with quickly okay let's not though
sir I'm not gonna be Zurich someone
higher rated than me unless opponent
physics back c4 okay
what's a mushi 96 is a move
we file at some point I think oh it's
been a while since I've looked at this
line yeah let's take you five I'm like
when I for I played this move family
Queen d6
yeah it's interesting structure double-a
pons ideas to the castle and maybe in
the overnight to be six come on Ricky
lucky AIDS defend the pond
hmm every key seven bishop
there's be six just want to simplify one
bring the knight to be six this could be
my last game if I lose take six six
dizzy dizzy with nickel thanks for
subbing oh okay wait maybe not so bad so
I wouldn't listen maybe this
I'm losing stuff though yeah I'm gonna
have to really try and fight for a draw
he's King outfit
what's the move here is each five
trying to calculate doesn't really help
though ig6 first
okay play King III you know you want to
King III it's not easy to make progress
for lights like d4 then the pawn is kind
of extended far can you three up like EE
5 mm and so boy the checks let's move
hmm it's not so pleasant check
let's go from behind I was having f5 I
just want to throw in rookie one check
g3 is a bit weak now work team on ideas
the pawns really trying to win okay they
just went up on I know I can't that's
true
hmm
carrying listening myths this should
just be a draw
unless opponent wants to go crazy mmm no
it's actually kind of crazy so I could
take yeah let's just take right
I'll take your next opponent maybe
losing his head the head is beginning to
roll dai yan i calls people to you and
sorry about that
oh okay opponents trying to bail out now
no draw Wu Kings call off Wow okay this
is actually getting interesting because
passed pawn Kings fell off a sheds a
shushes thanks for thanks for the sub
how to do this probably King enough six
at age five okay yeah play the smooth
I'm just trying to win the pong oh
that's annoying I have six you have six
well when the pawn so opponent basically
has to defend theoretically drawing rock
ending if I win this so that's a small
miracle I want to keep the Qinghua I
have to do kind of have to take let's
try this move I'll try this move first
let's try to smile
[Music]
making some progress it was like I'm
making progress opponent now kind of
passive
yeah so opponent had to draw but now
it's winning wow I wonder I was down
upon how's that end game was 403 I
looked three so um yeah this is uh this
is probably kind of well-known idea
rook G to easiest wrong so last chance
white hat is this position
Brooke g2 has only moved to draw it's a
very important time game to know this
happened uh between Kamsky and [ __ ]
bird
Chomsky and Ramirez in a u.s.
championship playoff we're calm see he
thought he was winning based on body
language and then Ramirez played Richie
- I think it was Richie - or work after
you it was some file lead school okay
I've won that well the term that
continues if I keep winning I'm I'm not
dropping out
so yeah I mean there is it's a little
bit tricky because it wasn't like the
typical Philidor position but I mean
type of position most chespin showed
understand how to draw kid okay
oh this opening oh we have a scotch
midnight rhino look it's a scotch let's
play Bishop b4 check Nicola thanks for
the bits
yeah bishop before check is interesting
line the beloved scotch and I'm black I
got tricked into it too I wanted to play
Stafford gambit
yeah it's um played 696 whoa it's John
John is back okay thanks for waking me
up slightly let's play this move let's
move let's move to 6 and the smooth
threading a fork of some sort and still
play this who is writing Bishop g4 and
the rook Bishop g4 looming
okay fun position if I five I can take
in and take with check its importance
not easy position White has time to
think
mm-hmm so I should probably just take
just be safe I'll have increments that's
gonna be a little bit tricky to win this
hmm
yeah white house a good compensation -
okay
stay focused 97 may be useful yeah this
is my NGO set up
Wow what does that move Oh interesting
move I wanna play f6 if I got the chance
but white plays f6 first takes takes I
have a g6 don't hurt me I've been hurt
so many times don't hurt me
[Music]
thanks you spits
don't know what to do here play this
move
I'm entirely sure also am I getting me
that I might be getting mated take there
though your opponent mr. Wynn play the
smooth very dangerous position
[Music]
Wow let's move
no wait what I was hanging cuz I was
hanging
No I lost a game I think that ends it
was a rough game where do I play one
more chat tell me what to do Oh what you
do one more one more one more
okay last one last one no matter what's
229 clear third get back to Tuan no I
could be here for a long time I just try
and get back to 2500 two hours no I
don't think so one more maybe I'll try
and wake up for the end of the
tournament okay
Smith moromete ooh we have a French
what's the play against French this is
always fun
I do G for
let's take
I just want a Castle queenside
okay mission accomplished
take your f3 it's not the most
impressive position it's not so
impressive
I'll try and play it my queen will come
to them
c5 and then to g3 I may be coming to f5
pawn may be coming to h6 Wow my Queens
almost getting trapped
h6 Queen d2 yeah I'm gonna be on the
defensive for a little bit
always flicking me one good thing my
Queens defended I can see that this is
attacking thing trades are coming yeah
it's gonna be positional game
I'm just worse position a force coming
unless I play for
I'll sort of this this is very difficult
position I think a for was stronger when
each coupon and beautiful h2 pond
hmm probably giving me mercy I'm each
three a good thing is that box pawns are
kind of fixed on dark squares outside
chance of hope back remade ideas yeah my
dreams so if I take one take once and
then take again I can takes interesting
okay let's put a rook on probably for
how's that before
before it's interesting yeah I think
I'll play B for John gifting a sub to
Kino Kino at the baller such a bowler so
ideas to trade got a passed pawn got the
only pass foam on the board I'll be left
with just disgusting pawn structure but
my bishop will come to life yeah how
many people like watched hours ago went
to sleep and then are now watching again
this move wow so many Me's so enemies og
space went to ski well that sounds fun
more fun than sleeping ok my bishop my
bishop might just be stuck forever my
King has life
I'm just scared that the Kings gonna
come to defy and my bishop will just be
forever trapped but what to do I guess
my bishops always pressuring the pawn
which means black will always need
something defending the pawn but if the
pawn states defended my Bishop has no
squares
opponent perplexed can live with that
yeah that's a good move yeah for force
kind of tricky mine Jay King d5 rookie
five check that's a good move
I think I can get away with this
there's only two reasonable Bishop
checks oh no am I getting mated getting
me dude what why I'm losing a bishop Wow
such a strong move
I didn't realize I'm getting needed
blocks threatening me didn't mind at
once that's so unfair good move I've
rookie six or bishop takes d4 both moves
really sad
that's really unfortunate I'm not
resigning because time scramble miracles
sometimes happen 5k pawns on light
squares Bishop can't touch my pawns
except I'm gonna be in zugzwang soon
so sad so so sad what to do I'm losing
all my pawns No Oh almost tell me it's
but not quite I'm not resigning because
of the famous Kasparov game because part
of like accidentally stalemated the
opponents all played the opponents
please resign I didn't listen to my
opponents username please resign now
please resign now is an anagram of
resign asleep now
people saying one more opponent deserve
to win that's rookie it was good enough
yeah a king C for man so this was
actually kind of a threat that's
difficult position okay
tigey says good stream I think so people
on YouTube if you've watched it this far
congratulations but also get some sleep
yeah and what I'll do is I'm gonna
export the video straight to YouTube so
when I end the stream on Twitch it'll be
the same for ending things on YouTube so
I do appreciate all the viewership all
the supports so many people I'm gonna
pause the tournament congratulations to
Valera
who's still playing 441 points that's
insane man
okay let's send a raid
well sing Sunday reads on Mortimer chess
[Music]
chess
yeah oh I know I okay I've met more than
more chess
he hosted me in Thailand or he showed me
around he gave me to her okay it's time
to read how do I do this
read
yeah John saying he looked super serious
I know two different faces both yeah
both very serious okay just to show the
tournament how many people played Wow
over 10,000 people
so I finish I'm sleeping and third
hopefully I can keep my third place
probably not though
okay thanks Nicola thinks I Brie
thanks again everyone else I'll be back
in the future what I'm more away goodbye